hello is my mic on you hear me alright
thanks so much for coming thanks so much
for coming to my talk here today this
talk in case you're not in the right
place is billed verses by software
systems at Jurassic Park and this talk
is going to be a bit of a retrospective
it's going to be an uncomfortably close
look at all of our successes and
failures that went into Jurassic Park
it's a retrospective as it were to share
our learnings from the Jurassic Park
project with the larger community now as
you may have seen there was a
documentary made about our work that
received some notoriety and showed off
our issues it got it got some notoriety
but it over dramatized the events it was
our first attempt and some there were
some unfortunate side effects but only
four people died only four people died
in Jurassic Park and I think we learned
a lot and will make our next time even
better one of our core problems which
we're going to talk about a lot more
today was perfectly articulated by one
of our consultants dr. Ian Malcolm who
said we were so preoccupied with whether
we could we didn't stop to think if we
should and I think he was specifically
talking about our choices about software
and automation systems in this text Who
am I my name is todd gardner i am the vp
of informatics and automation at a
company called engine engine is the
company that brought you Jurassic Park
here's where I fit into the overall org
structure so here at the top of the
leadership team was our CEO John Hammond
I reported to him and Dennis who you
might be familiar with from the
documentary reported up through me my
peers were ray Arnold from operations
and robert muldoon from security so
that's kind of where I fit in and why I
can speak to this
so as my good friend ray Arnold used to
say hold on to your butt's let's get
started so first I want to tell you some
stories about build and some things that
we built for Jurassic Park when we build
something build is inherently unique
when we want to build a new piece of
software we are going to solve our
problem
with that software better than anybody
else could we're gonna solve it for us
for the things that we think are
important to us and only those things no
one else or it is going to solve our
problems quite as perfectly as we're
gonna solve them for ourselves and build
us fun when we're building software
that's what we want to do we're
Engineers we're coders we want to code
we want to solve these new problems it's
exciting building new things allows us
to try out new ideas new bits of
technology it allows us to escape the
tedium of working on those boring legacy
systems that make all of the money in
our organizations but have all these
constraints that we can't escape
building new pieces of software allows
us to improve our team's morale by
exposing them to this excitement and tap
in and harness the passion of our people
one example of harnessing our passion
was with Dennis we were able to get
Dennis who was truly a ninja developer
by tapping into his passion for building
security systems Dennis really wanted to
build a security system from the ground
up the door locks the monitoring systems
the video surveillance all of these
things he was really passionate about
building himself from the ground up and
so we were able to get him on our team
for far cheaper than we could have
otherwise by tapping into his passion to
build these things now as a consequence
of that when we build our software the
happy path of the problem at hand is
never where the problem lies as soon as
we start digging into the details is
where we find all of the complications
handling the edge cases handling the
failure modes backing up the system
making sure our backups will actually be
able to be restored handling the
security of it this is where all of the
real costs in building complex software
are lies and it's the majority of the
work when we take a project from having
a neat idea that solves a problem to
actually fully operationalizing it and
this is no more evident than in Dennis's
security system things like this things
like the security system involved a very
complex array of software and Internet
of Things devices
that didn't handle all of the potential
failure modes things like door locks
this should never have happened
a door lock should always have a manual
override in case a raptor wants to get
through the door
you should never need power for your
door locks to work and this is one of
the many edge cases that our security
system failed now another issue to be
concerned about with with building
software is the bus factor many of you
might be familiar with this term it's
how many people in your organization
would need to be hit by a bus before you
were in trouble now on Jurassic Park we
didn't have any buses so we didn't call
it this but we did have Dilophosaurus so
we called it the Dilophosaurus factor
how many of our engineers would need to
be eaten by Dilophosaurus for us to be
in trouble
and unfortunately that answer was one
one engineer had to be eaten by
Dilophosaurus and we were in trouble
having a low Dilophosaurus factor or a
low bus factor for your organization's
creates all kinds of sustainability
issues it creates fiefdom zuv knowledge
within your organization's how will your
teammates help out take over fix a bug
restore an outage when you're
unavailable for whatever non
Dilophosaurus related reason the
maintenance time that goes into our
software patching bugs security issues
integrating with other systems debugging
why the headlights are running on car
batteries a thousand little annoying
tasks the makeup that make up the
majority of the work these things are
going to pop up months and months after
we initially build a piece of software
and deploy it but represents the
majority of the time investment that's
going to go in to building our own
software and growing it this is where
the true cost of building software lies
and could be as much as 90% of the total
amount of engineering time you put into
a project doesn't come from the build it
comes from the maintaining the handling
of patching part of that is handling
outages outages are part of this
maintenance time and how do we know if
we're going to be able to handle this as
we know
things don't always go as planned and
handling recovery is part of our costs
do we know how to restart our services
our backups good when we restore our
backups is the system going to come back
online the way we expect this going to
our backups good and current here's a
fancy tool that I think I found online
it's from a company called Baer metrics
and it's a start-up calculator or a
software calculator and it allows you to
compare the absolute costs of software
building versus buying just the actual
cost part of it not all of the fuzzy
feelings around it and so what you can
do is you can compare what could I buy a
piece of software for and then what's it
going to take me to build it you can
find this out on Bayer metrics website
under like software calculator I believe
and so in this particular thing we could
have built a security system and
leveraged a cloud security system for
about $3,000 a year or in our case we
decided to build it and it took two
engineers myself and Dennis which we
paid an average salary of a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars a year it took
us two weeks to build out that first
prototype of our security system and
then we probably spent another day every
month patching it adding features to it
whatever using these rough numbers this
was never a sound financial decision it
cost us 90 100 dollars to build the
system originally and then 7800 dollars
every year just to maintain it just that
one day a month adds up in terms of
costs and so we were losing compared to
just buying a cloud-based alternative we
were losing $4,800 a year and this would
never have a positive ROI excuse me but
aside from the absolute costs involved
in building a piece of software the more
important cost is the opportunity cost
what are the things that your team could
have been doing instead of building a
piece of security software each of our
companies has something amazing at its
heart something we do better than
everybody else and what could we what
could our engineers have done with
time if we hadn't focused on our core
instead what could we have done in terms
of building a better genetics process
engineering a better dinosaur and just
purchasing a security software from
somebody else so the cost to build this
thing out was first the developer time
the cost of our develop Dennis to build
the piece of software originally second
the maintenance time all the costs that
went in to maintaining that system
recovering from the outage and then
third those opportunity costs beyond
just the strict costs involved there are
a bunch of soft or things up around
building software and that's when you
build a lot of complex pieces of
software and try to integrate them into
your own system you need a high level of
maturity in your organization to be
successful at that building software is
complex not just the software itself but
all of the processes and people and
interactions that go in and making that
successful to be successful with a lot
of pieces of software you're gonna need
ownership polities who owns that
codebase who's going to control when it
gets changed when it gets released when
it gets patched what's the planning
horizon what happens if this API doesn't
talk to that API successfully
understanding these becomes
exponentially harder the more pieces of
custom software that you build in your
organization and that maturity frankly
is not fun it's boring we don't want to
sit around as a leadership team of
Jurassic Park discussing change control
we want to be figuring out what the next
dinosaur we want to build is succeeding
at this demands that level of maturity
if we want to build every one of our
systems on our own and so an important
question to ask as you grow the amount
of software that you build in-house is
do you have this level of maturity does
your organization have these processes
these controls in place to really even
be successful at it and even if you do
do you want to be do you want to have
that into your organization or do you
want to be a small fast team and rely on
other people to do those sort of things
maturity is a little overrated
so now I want to switch and talk about
buying software because we bought plenty
of software at Jurassic Park as well now
buy in this terminology is a bit of an
old term the build versus by comparison
came about in an earlier era of software
where it meant I'm either going to build
my own mainframe or I'm going to buy a
mainframe from IBM or Oracle or
something and that doesn't really mean
that anymore because we don't really do
that very much anymore but I could mean
lots of things it could mean I download
a package off of github it could mean
that I license a piece of software and I
install it it could mean that I am
paying a subscription to a service in a
cloud any of these things is I'm
leveraging software that other people
have built for me and they all have
about the same pros and cons involved
and so rather than just strictly build
versus buy I mean build versus use are
you going to build something yourself
are you going to solve this problem
yourself or are you gonna use somebody
else's tech to solve this problem so
let's talk about some some buys why
would I buy the first reason I'd buy is
because it's fast I can solve a problem
really really fast because somebody else
has already solved it for me
it would have taken us a very very long
time for Jurassic Park to build to
design and build and manufacture our own
vehicles so instead we bought them we
just bought old explorers from Ford and
then we adapted them to our purposes our
unique constraints we were able to focus
on the things that made us unique things
like adding night-vision poise and
resistant windows and a t-rex strength
rollcage those are the things that we're
really unique to our vehicles not the
transmission and the wheels but as I
think we all know by kind of sucks like
there's really nothing worse as an
engineer than coming in on Monday and
figuring out that your next project that
you're getting put on is going to be an
s AP integration project where you're
gonna have to write a bunch of
middleware to integrate with the rest of
your systems oh my god that's awful
right you do not want to be part of that
project that's going to be that's going
to drain your talent so you're going to
be reading other people's documentation
now we did that plenty of times at
Jurassic Park here
an example of one of our software
installation projects and this was a
really complex team effort here we're
trying to bring in a new piece of
software and we have an installation
team who's handling the actual you know
hands-on keyboard we have a security
team making sure everything is going to
go off off as planned we have the
operations team like checking it out
making sure everything is happening as
as they expect and we even had a project
manager with a shotgun ready to
intervene should anything go wrong but
despite all of that 55 percent of our
and in general software projects still
fail
there's an old IT adage that 75% of
software projects fail and I don't know
where that actually came from I can't
find an original source but here I found
an original source from just 2016 that
showed that 55% of them are still
failing based on a study from cio.com
and this feels right like I've been a
part of a lot of projects that have
failed due to all these complexity
reasons and all of these this failure
stems into a feeling called not invented
here syndrome that it happens into a lot
of organizations that because buying and
installing and integrating software is
often painful it often sucks it's often
something we don't want to do we have a
tendency as engineers to prefer to build
our own stuff I don't want to use that
stuff I don't trust that person's code I
don't want to deal with all of that pain
I'm just gonna build it myself it's
gonna be easier and we did that a lot of
Jurassic Park we had a tendency to over
build here in this particular screen we
see a bunch of systems that we built
ourself we built our own weather
monitoring system we built our own tour
operations we built our own telephones
we built our own video surveillance
these are things that weren't unique to
Jurassic Park we didn't have a unique
concern to manage the weather beyond
what another organization would do we
could have bought a weather management
system from you know a skiing resort or
a different zoo or something like that
and it would have been fine but in some
cases it made a lot of sense to buy
especially when we had things that
weren't particularly unique to us so in
a lot of cases we can rely on a piece of
software to implement an industry
standard workflow at Jurassic Park we
had some complex engineering efforts for
example we had a process that we called
design to hatch and it was all of the
steps that went in from designing a
particular genome to hatching a new
asset for our park in some cases we had
we had a lot of different pieces of
software that went into this process in
some cases like for example here's a
shot of our egg management software we
didn't need to invest and create our own
process we were able to get a process
kind of for free through our robotics
management system that had a process on
how to manage eggs it could manage eggs
from any kind of asset from chickens
from ostriches for whatever we didn't
have to invent our own process on how to
manage eggs the system assumed a
predefined flow of work and that was
fine we didn't need to create our own we
saved a lot of heartache by just
adopting the process that came along
with that software but in other cases
what we were doing was truly unique and
superior like in our genetics testing we
needed software that could adapt to our
needs that we could configure and make
it into exactly what we wanted it to be
now I can't tell you a lot about that
software because it's all still under
NDA however a related corollary would be
a very popular tool called Atlassian
JIRA JIRA is a very common example of a
tool that has high levels of system
configurability if your process is truly
unique and special and makes you
superior you can take a tool like JIRA
and configure it into implementing your
process now that doesn't mean that your
process is great and if you do this with
a bad process configuring a system to
you're bad process just makes that
process go bad faster but if you have
something truly unique you can make
tools with high levels of
configurability work really well for you
when you're buying a piece of software
you need to be very aware of vendor
lock-in because all the vendors are
doing this if you go down this path the
more you customize your software the
more you tailor your particular needs to
that platform or to that software to
that tool you
or locking yourself into using it more
for example if you're building a piece
of software in AWS or in Microsoft Azure
those platforms are both trying to lock
you in they're building a set of
constraints in the side of api's that
enable you to go a lot faster but if
should you ever want to move away from
those platforms you are making it
exponentially harder for you to ever
switch away because you've codified your
system in such a way that it is tailored
to those platforms recreating all of
that configuration elsewhere is
incredibly expensive and all the vendors
are doing this it's a term that the
vendors call making their products
sticky and it's not something that one
company is more evil than another every
platform is trying to do this because it
enables you enable those vendors to have
a higher level of retention that's
totally fine and I'm not speaking ill of
them for doing it you just need to be
aware of it when you're making these
decisions that they're trying to lock
you in and the more you customize your
software to that platform the harder
it's going to be to ever leave now on
the flip side of that when you buy a
piece of software you enable new people
coming into your organization to quickly
get up to speed with what's going on in
this particular case we had a new
employee jumping in to cover for some of
our are missing staff and they were able
to quickly understand what was going on
because we use industry standard tools
to manage this system she was able to
quickly get up on her feet and solve an
important problem for us now this is an
excellent case however in many cases of
Jurassic Park we weren't able to
leverage this in our larger software
systems we used a very complex
service-oriented architecture where we
built our own customized tools we had
our own custom session management tool
our own custom authentication tool our
own custom data sharing tool our own
custom key value pair tool we didn't
leverage industry standard tools or even
things that would be known outside of
our organization because we built them
ourselves but the consequence of that is
when we hire somebody new to come into
our
they had to learn all of the different
quarks all the different constraints all
the different ways that we had built
things that were different than
everybody else
and it took upwards of six months for an
engineer to become really productive in
our system because they had to learn all
of the things that made us unique
we also bought software from new
companies from startups here is one
particular company that you might have
heard of it got a lot of tech press it's
a company called Raptor and Raptor
Raptor promised a new paradigm shift in
security systems what they claimed to do
is that they could build a custom
security system around an asset that you
thought was completely unsecure vil it
was going to completely transform how
how your unsecured ballasts worked and
at dress park we had a lot of assets
that had a high level of security risk
it got a ton of press everybody was
saying good things about raptor but like
most tech press it was artificial most
hot new tech things are not hot new tech
things because they're good there are
hot new tech things because their
investors are pumping them up as hot new
tech things and unfortunately this is
the majority of the tech press today it
was pumped up by the venture capitalist
that were backing them and like most of
these companies they were fundamentally
unprofitable and unsustainable they'd
taken so much outside money to either
grow and become the next great American
security company that dominated the
space or they would disappear entirely
and unfortunately late one Thursday
night Raptor disappeared many of you
might have seen this article in
TechCrunch where Oracle acquired raptor
for basically nothing one day one Raptor
ran out of money they acquired assets
they acquired the people and basically
shut the whole thing down because as
core this hot tech startup was
unsustainable
and when we needed them the most they
were not there for us so when we're
looking at buying a piece of software
understanding the sustainability of
that software is really important is
this company profitable are they making
enough money to continue to do this
thing or are they just going to
disappear one day when they run out of
money
this applies not only to companies but
to open-source projects if we're
building our piece of software based on
open-source project this run by some guy
running his nights and weekends
ploughing it into this open source
project eventually they are going to
burn out they're gonna rage quit that
and be like so fed up with you losing
all of their free time to this
open-source project and they're just
gonna disappear are you willing to step
in and own that open source project
after that and if you're not why are you
depending on it all of the things we
build when we leverage a piece of
software from somebody else we need to
think about the sustainability of that
software is it still going to be around
later so address park we made a bunch of
mistakes we got some well-deserved mud
on our faces we failed me as a VP I
failed four of our people are dead my
lawyers dead the project managers dead
mr. Arnold's dead dennis is dead but I
am excited about next time next time
we're gonna do it right last time our
system wasn't very flexible we made a
bunch of bad decisions but next time
we're gonna build it in JavaScript and
it's going to be way better and we have
some new engineers coming on board this
is a new engineer named Newman who we've
just hired as a new developer Newman is
fresh at a code school after leaving the
u.s. post office and he's got some
exciting a ideas he wants to try about
distributed systems and machine learning
that I think you're really gonna make
the next dress park better and I'm
trying to be better John and I are
thinking about what are the questions
that we should have asked as the VP of
Technology I got a little too far away
from the actual technology in my role
and I didn't ask the right questions as
we were building our software and so
this time I want to ask some better
questions questions like what is the
impact of failure of this decision when
we're looking at buying a new piece of
software or building that software what
the impact of if this goes wrong do
people die does the business lose some
money is an engineering convenience this
asking these questions allows us to
focus our energy and attention on the
problems that need that energy and
attention and not sweat on the small
stuff too often we get into analysis
paralysis on questions that don't matter
just pick something and move on don't
get sucked into these things so you can
focus on making sure you make the best
decisions for the systems where this is
most critical now when I was getting my
MBA at the University of Oslo we heard
this a lot you should build software for
competitive advantage or buy it for
competitive parity and what that means
is if I have something that is truly
unique
I should be building that I want to have
an advantage over my competitors I want
to be better at them but if it's a part
of my system where I just need to be
good enough I need to be as good at
managing feeding as any other zoo I can
buy a system to do that if that's not
what's truly unique about me now this is
a maybe not the most clear way to
putting it so another one of our
consultants mr. Dylan Beatty phrased it
while on a tour in this way if that if
you couldn't sell it buy it now he this
is still using the old terminology so
it's really more about whether or not
you could contribute it if you couldn't
build something in such a way that you
could contribute it back to an
open-source community or launch a piece
of software business of your own based
on it if it's not unique enough and
valuable enough that other people could
get use off of it as well whether or not
they actually do is immaterial but
whether you could then you could build
it but if not is it really worthwhile to
do it does the world need another print
to PDF tool chain does the world need
another comma-separated file reader I
don't know that it does I think these
are solved problems that you could
probably leverage from somebody else's
tool chain
and I want to recognize that all of us
as engineers have a bias for building we
all want to solve the problem ourselves
here we are in a code review after
Dennis left we're reviewing a bunch of
his code and noticed that in his choices
he had this obvious bias to build
everything to million lines of like this
weird nested code that did everything it
was very complex to understand and
Dennis had this bias to build everything
and we need to recognize that that's
happening so that we can try to avoid it
next time and make these decisions
objectively and clear minded but
regardless of the decisions we make it's
important that we do not make those
decisions company policy nobody wants to
be an organization where the policy is
that we buy all of our software nobody
wants to be in the organization where
you build it either these decisions are
all unique and every time you're
approached with a question of do I buy
something or do I build it you need to
approach the context of that question
independently so here's an example that
we're looking at right now so the new
Jurassic Park is going to be built in
JavaScript which I'm super excited about
but more like most JavaScript apps it's
going to break unexpectedly from time to
time so we're already looking at for
better ways to understand how that's
going to happen and so we're looking to
build some air monitoring now we could
build it and what I want to think about
if we're gonna build it is what are the
edge cases going to be how do we really
understand how big this software is
gonna be and how much would it cost us
to build it so if we were to go out and
try and do this ourselves there's a
couple of main things that we would need
to do first we'd need to write some
JavaScript to gather error data from our
systems an agent something to pull
together crashes and tell us when they
happen and then we would need to store
them somewhere there's lots of places we
could store it elastic is a good tool
that we could use to store a bunch of
this data and then we would need to
visualize that day we need to be able to
see it I don't want to be querying a
you know a datastore every time I want
to see my errors so we could use another
tool called Cabana and we have a basics
of an error monitoring system right here
now we get into the edge cases because I
don't just want this I don't want to
have to log into this every day and see
what's going on I'm probably gonna want
some alerting
I'm probably gonna want some jobs that
run periodically and say hey is anything
weird happening do we have more airs now
and then we did an hour ago is this
thing bubbling up do they're an anomaly
in our data and then we have to
operationalize this as well we have to
figure out how we're gonna back this
data up what infrastructure are we gonna
run it on is there a security issue here
could people break in and steal our data
by stealing our monitoring system in
logs what happens if the monitoring
system goes down the monitors of the
monitors go down do we need to know do
we need to care how do we handle that
and so if we put all that in back into
that calculator we could figure out like
how much is this gonna cost
so Newman thinks he can build it himself
and we Newman's you know a new grad so
we're gonna pay him a little less than
we paid Dennis Newman's going to get a
hundred thousand dollars a year
he thinks he can build it in two weeks
but you know and she's always kind of
underestimate how long things are gonna
take so let's say four weeks and then
maybe one day a month just to maintain
it update it patch it make sure
everything is running or if we put a
comparable in to what we would cost us
to buy something is there's tools on the
market that we could pay about twenty
seven hundred dollars a year and get
similar functionality and using these
numbers this never quite works out
financially it would cost us seventy six
hundred dollars to build it initially
and thirty two hundred dollars a year in
that one day a month to maintain it and
so we're losing five hundred bucks from
a year just to build it ourselves to own
it ourselves independent of all the
complexity and all of the opportunity
costs that we might have lost in order
to pull that off so in a comparable
instead we could have looked at other
tools what could we have bought in this
space and there's a number of tools in
the space that you could leverage one of
them that I think is particularly good
is it come
called track jeaious which is a cloud
service that you could just drop in and
do it and so what would be the things
that we'd be concerned about here well
first that it's fast is we don't have to
spend any time figuring this out you
just sign up and it works and we don't
have to build it ourselves we don't have
to figure out the edge cases we don't to
figure out how to operationalize it it
just works but sustainability is
important and so how do you know if this
thing is still going to be around when
you need it and so one of the ways to
evaluate this is by looking at outside
money when a company takes outside money
I'll hi hi
ninety-nine percent of the time outside
money beats a company unsustainable
because it puts tremendous pressure on
that company to grow fast or die trying'
and speaking with the leadership team of
track jeaious they've said they've never
taken any outside money and they don't
intend to they're internally profitable
and so that that gives a good sign that
they're going to be sustainable and be
around when we need them and most
importantly what is the opportunity cost
here so we could just drop in and
outside script and there's some risks
that we don't understand what it's doing
and there's an outside vendor involved
but I could instead take that for weeks
and have Dennis or have Newman build us
an awesome new dinosaur for the park so
I think we're gonna trial track yes and
Newman is already liking of us quite a
bit so I think we might have a winner
here so this was build versus buy some
stories about Jurassic Park and so the
important takeaway here are some
questions that we should ask when we're
buying when we're choosing to build or
buy a piece of software and the first
thing is understanding what our own
biases what do we actually want to do
and why is that is that the correct
initial feeling that we should do then
what is the impact of a failure in this
disk ace if this is a big deal if people
are gonna die we should spend a lot of
time thinking about this to make sure we
make the right decision but if the
failure of this is that somebody has to
restart a service on Monday
maybe we shouldn't worry about this so
much whether to build or buy it think
about whether or not we
sell it or we could contribute it is
this something that is unique enough
that we could build something
interesting and valuable off of it is it
unique enough that it's worth building
ourselves and what could we do instead
if we didn't build it and we just bought
it from somebody else what could we do
with our time
what valuable thing could we create on
our own and whatever our decision is
whether it is something internal that
we're going to build or externally that
we're gonna boo by is it a sustainable
choice do we have the maturity in our
organization to run another piece of
software successfully is our busk or our
Dilophosaurus factor low enough or high
enough that this isn't going to create a
problem or if we buy it is the company
that we're buying it from or the
open-source maintainer that we're using
this from are they sustainable are they
going to still be around and working on
this piece of software in a year in two
years in five years so that we can
depend on it in the way that we need to
so with these questions in our inner
pocket I think we're set up for a lot of
future success and I'm really excited
about the nest next Jurassic Park it's
already coming together we have a site
under construction right now I'm really
excited to show you it's going to be
Jurassic Park and who vidoe Islands and
it's going to be great we have job
postings already open so if you're an
engineer looking for a spot let me know
we're currently looking for engineers
and Raptor handlers and there is a great
benefits package that goes along with it
that does not include life insurance
this was built versus by address park
thank you so much for coming there's a
pile of stickers from Trek jeaious
sitting on the table if you'd like to
take one just put a little green card in
there when you do thank you so much
[Applause]